The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREW LO: Any questions
from last lecture?
Where we left off last time
was the adaptive markets
hypothesis.
The fact that markets are not
always in everywhere efficient,
but rather they satisfy the
following six properties
that I listed at the
end of last lecture.
Individuals act in
their own self-interest,
but they make mistakes.
However, they learn and
adapt, and competition drives
that adaptation and innovation.
Natural selection,
essentially, is the mechanism
that shapes the survival of
the heuristics And in the end,
the only thing that
matters is survival.
Now I illustrated how
heuristics develop
by giving you an example of
the problem of getting dressed
in the morning.
And I pointed out
that each of us
have our own heuristics
that have been developed
over many, many
years of selection
of various different sorts.
So when you take
this all together
and you put them
into a framework that
tries to focus on
understanding market dynamics,
you get a number of
implications that
are actually quite different
from that of efficient markets.
Let me tell you what they are.
I'll give you some examples.
One of the implications is
that the risk-reward trade-off
the relationship between risk
and expected rate of return,
like the CAPM's
security market line.
That's not stable over
time or over circumstances,
because individual
preferences are not stable
over time or over circumstances.
I'll give you an
example of that.
Anybody know somebody who
has lived through the Great
Depression, OK, so grandparents
or great-grandparents?
My guess is that if
you talk to them,
or if you even
observe their habits,
they're actually quite
different from your parents
and yourselves in
terms of how frugal
they, are how careful
they are with money,
with resources, even something
as simple as turning off
the lights.
A friend of mine is a customer
a very wealthy family.
They own a private business.
And so their family's
net worth today
is probably in the
order of $300 million,
which, even in today's
economy is worth a lot.
Actually, it's worth more than
what it used to be worth now.
And so this family, the
patriarch, the matriarch
is their grandmother, who lived
through the Great Depression.
And she lives in Lower
Manhattan in a relatively small,
nondescript apartment,
despite the fact
that the family, you
know, my friend's parents,
live in a beautiful penthouse
apartment on Park Avenue.
And they keep asking
the grandmother
to move in with them.
And she refuses.
She just thinks it's a waste.
It's embarrassing.
And when she comes to visit
them, she'll take the bus.
She refuses to take taxis
just from Lower Manhattan
to Midtown.
And so, you know, my friend,
you know, pleads with her.
You know, Nana, why
are you doing this?
You know, we have more money
than we'll ever be able to use.
You can afford to take a taxi.
Let us send a car for you.
Why do you do this?
It's dangerous for you to
take the subway or the bus.
And she's like 95 years old.
And she says to
him, listen, Sonny.
You don't remember
the days that I do,
when I had to stand in line
and wait for my dinner,
not knowing whether or not I
was going to get me by the time
I got to that end of that line.
So don't you tell me that we
have more money than will ever
be able to spend.
I'm sure you've heard that.
Those of you who know people who
lived through the depression,
you've heard that.
These individuals were indelibly
altered by their experiences.
They're not the same
person before, as after,
living through such
difficult times.
And you're not going
to change them.
So my friend has stopped trying.
And so he just
does what he can in
order to make her life easier,
but realizing that she simply
can't enjoy the
same kinds of things
that he does, because she lived
through such traumatic times.
So if you understand that,
if you acknowledge that there
are people that are indelibly
altered by tough times,
then, in the same way, people
can be indelibly altered
by really good times as well.
As I said last time, you learn
nothing from your successes,
right?
Because you succeeded,
what's there to learn?
Do more of the same.
But that affects the
way you think as well.
And so what we think of as
this beautiful mathematical
relationship, this risk-reward
trade-off, the CAPM,
the CAPM works if all of the
assumptions that I specified
are true.
But those assumptions
are predicated
on people acting rationally.
If people don't act rationally
for whatever reason,
if they're emotionally
traumatized,
if the balance between emotion
and logical deliberation
has been permanently
altered, then the theory
is not going to work.
So you have to understand that
when you're looking at markets,
you're looking at
the complexities
of the interactions among
various different people
with different balances
of logical deliberation
and emotional response.
So one of the
things that says is
that risk premia,
the expected return
on risky assets as a whole,
is not a universal constant
like, you know, gravity.
It changes over time
and over circumstances.
It was going to
be quite different
if we had continuing prosperity
over the next five years
as to where we're
likely to be headed now.
It's just different.
We have a different path
that we're going to follow.
And so as things change, market
dynamics will change with them.
Yeah, Zeke.
AUDIENCE: So last
time, we had talked
about when you give somebody
[INAUDIBLE] that [INAUDIBLE]
and so on.
And you said that lasts
for a couple of hours.
ANDREW LO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So with combined
with what you're saying today,
are you connecting
the two and suggesting
that such huge events actually
change our biology permanently
for years?
Or do you think that
there's a different reason
behind that sort of learning?
ANDREW LO: I'm saying
that it can change not so
much our biology,
but rather, it can
change our decision-making
abilities for years
to come, in the same way that
you know your grandmother
or great-grandmother
was indelibly affected
by living through
the Great Depression,
or through the Holocaust, or
through some extraordinary
emotional trauma,
in the same way
we will be affected by these
sets of circumstances for years
to come.
Right?
That's it.
Ingrid.
AUDIENCE: I was really
impressed about two weeks ago
that I heard the different
networks, the channel
lists trying to convince people
not to getting them to buy
Christmas presents,
and people are
going to complain because
they could not not
buy gifts to their kids.
And where I come from,
if you don't have money,
you don't have
money [INAUDIBLE]..
So it was really surprising
to see how that consumption
mindset was so, so strong here.
ANDREW LO: That's right.
And you know, that's a very
unusual mindset for the United
States, because we are the
land of consumers, right?
I mean, consumption is
what drives this economy,
for better or for worse.
You know, that is what has
made this country as wealthy
as it has.
And so, it is a very difficult
time when we actually
have to all pull back.
And you know there are some
individuals that would argue
that you shouldn't pull back.
You should keep on spending,
because if everybody
keeps on spending, then
somehow, magically, we will be,
stay richer.
That doesn't quite work.
There's an adding up
constraint somewhere.
So wealth, if it's
lost, you know,
it's lost in a certain sense.
And you can't create
something out of nothing.
But I think there are some
issues about government's role
in being able to maintain a
certain degree of spending.
So we're going to get to
that in a few minutes.
But you're absolutely right.
This is a very big change
from where we were just
even a few months ago.
Other implications
of adaptive markets
is that limited arbitrage,
the so-called free lunches
that we talked about, that
can exist from time to time.
There are free
lunches on occasion,
because you can think of the
free lunches as opportunities
that a certain group of
individuals in the economy
have identified
which may not last.
And so over time, those
arbitrageurs end up
getting eaten away
by the arbitrageurs.
But they still do exist
from time to time.
Free lunch programs
may not exist,
in other words consistent
arbitrageurs time and again.
That is much, much more
difficult to come by.
But as a result, strategies
will wax and wane
through different cycles.
And the way it does so
is exactly the same way
that a beautiful, green
pasture can come and go
based upon ecological dynamics.
In particular, a green pasture
becomes a favorite spot
for sheep to graze on.
And after a while, as the sheep
graze and get fat and multiply,
they have more and more
effect on that pasture.
Pretty soon, with so many sheep
grazing on that same pasture,
the pasture is depleted.
And after it's
depleted, what happens
to the sheep population?
It declines.
And the population declines,
the pasture grows back,
and the cycle begins
all over again.
Well, I have news for you.
That pasture, you can
think of as profits.
And the sheep, you can
think of as all of you.
You're, the investors.
And if it's profitable for
you to invest in something
you will keep doing it,
and doing it, and doing it
until there's no more pasture.
That's what happened with
mortgage-backed securities.
There's no more pasture now.
It's pretty much gone.
It's going to be
hard to make money
in that market for a while.
So all the sheep, they're
going to go away now.
And over time, it
will come back.
It may take a while,
but it will come back.
And that's where
cycles come from.
It's the exact same mechanism.
This is not an
analogy or a metaphor.
I'm describing
exactly the mechanism
by which certain biological
entities interact
with their environment.
And we are biological entities.
We're creatures.
And we interact in
our environment.
The only difference
between us and sheep
is that we consume
dollars instead of grass.
And so the dynamics are
really very much the same.
And the bottom line, I
said, is that survival
is all that matters.
What any business cares about
in general is surviving.
And as you push
for survival, a lot
of the effects that you see in
typical evolutionary systems
will emerge in economies.
So let me talk specifically
about some very, very
concrete examples of
these kinds of dynamics.
I'll give you just a couple.
The first example comes
from the hedge fund
industry, and in particular,
from very, very simple--
a simple observation about the
efficiency of the stock market.
When we talked about the
random walk hypothesis
a few weeks ago, we
mentioned that the idea
behind the random walk
is that if prices fully
reflect all available
information, then certainly,
you shouldn't be able
to predict what's
going to happen
to prices tomorrow
based upon what happened
to prices last week, right?
In other words, just because
we had a positive return
over the last five days,
that positive return
shouldn't give you
any hint as to whether
or not the next five days
will be positive or negative,
because all the information
of the last five days
has been incorporated
into today's price.
So at every point in
time, it's a fair game.
It's a Martingale.
Well if you believe
that, then what
that says is that the
first-order autocorrelation
of monthly stock returns
should be about zero.
In other words, the correlation
between last month's return
and this month's return
should be statistically
indistinguishable from zero.
Because if it weren't,
if it were strictly
positive or negative, then
you'd have information
to be able to base a
trading strategy on, right?
For example, if
it were positive,
then if last month's
return were positive,
you can bet the
next month's return
will continue to be positive.
So you'll make a bigger
bet on the stock market.
You'll develop a
trading strategy
that can beat the market.
Efficient markets hypothesis
would say you can't do that.
You can't come up with these
kind of trading strategies.
In other words, stock
prices follow random walks.
Autocorrelation should be 0.
All right, well,
let's take a look.
This is the rolling
five-year serial correlation
coefficient-- first-order
autocorrelation coefficient
for stock returns on a
monthly basis for the S&P
composite index from January
of 1871 to April of 2003.
That's a lot of data, right?
And if these are five-year
rolling window correlations--
so every five years, I'm going
to calculate the correlation
coefficient between month
T and month T minus 1,
and it should be 0.
But let's take a
look at what happens.
In the 1800s, the
late 1800s, there
was a fair bit of positive
correlation, correlation
around 40% or 50%.
And then, towards the
end of the century,
the correlation goes
down, then it goes up.
Then it goes way down
in the early 1900s.
Then it goes up, then it
goes down, then it goes up.
During the 1970s
here, there's a bit
of a period where it goes
down, then it goes up,
then it goes down,
then it goes way up.
It shoots way up in the 1990s.
And then, since the 1990s,
it's been relatively low.
And actually, if you extended
it to the last few years,
you'd see that it's
still pretty low.
This diagram shows
that market efficiency,
as measured by the first-order
autocorrelation first of all,
it's not zero.
But more importantly, it does
not decline monotonically
over time.
Markets are not getting more
and more and more efficient.
There's a cycle of efficiency.
There are periods where the
market is very efficient.
And there are periods
where it's not.
And these periods are
determined by the population
of investors that are
interacting with each other.
There are periods where markets
are extremely efficient,
because you've got very
sophisticated investors
in the market.
But during the 1990s,
that wasn't one of them,
because what was happening
during the 1990s?
Who was trading here?
Anybody know?
Who?
Tech.
But who were the traders?
AUDIENCE: Everybody was.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
Retail investors, everybody.
You know, the librarian,
the pharmacist, mom and pop,
grandma, they were all
trading on E-trade on all
of these various
different trading sites.
And as a result, the market
became relatively inefficient.
And you can see this.
You can see this
as clear as day.
By the way, right
around here was
where some of the equity market
neutral hedge funds, like DE
Shaw decided to go into
business and made a lot of money
in this period.
It's gotten a lot
harder now, no doubt.
But my guess is that
over the next few years,
you may see markets
becoming more inefficient.
Why is that?
Why might that be over
the next couple of years?
Any guesses?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Because people are
pulling out of the market?
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
People, particularly
sophisticated investors,
like hedge funds, are
pulling out of the market
because they're getting
blown out of the water.
They're losing a lot of money.
They don't have enough
to run their businesses.
They're pulling out.
And so whatever's left may not
be as efficient as it once was.
That's adaptive markets.
That's all.
Economic systems are not
like physical systems.
We're not approaching any
kind of steady state limit.
We're interacting
with each other.
And during certain
time periods, we're
going to be very efficient.
And then, by the
way, finance there
is going to work quite well.
But then there are going to
be periods that are crazy.
And during those crazy
periods, market prices
may not fully reflect all
available information,
in which case, markets will
not be as reliable as finance
theory makes them out to be.
So when you apply
your 401 techniques,
you've got to start by
asking the question,
do those assumptions that
we made, do they hold?
Is this a reasonable
period of time
for which finance theory will
dictate what prices should be?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: If expected
return of the stock markets
let's say 10%, then the other
correlation shouldn't be zero.
It should be around--
there's supposed to be some
correlation when the market is
efficient is when the next--
ANDREW LO: No, because
remember, the correlation
is the covariance divided by the
variance in excess of the mean.
These are deviations
from mean, right?
So it doesn't matter if
it's 10%, or 20%, or 5%.
If there's a trend,
the mean basically
subtracts that trend off.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: There are a few
dips like, [INAUDIBLE]
like [INAUDIBLE] does a dip.
Like do you have an explanation
about like why that happened?
ANDREW LO: Well,
the explanation,
at least during the recent
periods, I have one for you.
I don't know about
going back here.
I can conjecture.
But there are a
lot of other things
going on here that I can't say
that I've really researched.
But over here, I can
tell you what happened,
which is that the
internet bubble burst.
And then retail investors,
they left the market.
And who was left but
sophisticated, institutional
traders.
And they took advantage
of whatever correlation
there might be.
And that basically bit
away any other profits
that might have remained.
So over the last, I don't know,
maybe five to eight years,
long/short equity market
neutral and long/short equity
strategies, that are
the basis for taking
advantage of these
kind of correlations,
have grown dramatically.
And the profits have
declined significantly.
Markets have gotten
more efficient.
And you know, I would argue that
during certain periods of time,
for example, during the
1950s, during this period,
there were situations where
markets got more efficient
because certain institutional
investors came in,
and retail investors left.
So by looking at the population
dynamics of the market ecology,
you see, I mean, that
language that I just used
is language that evolutionary
biologists would use.
It's not something that
economists would ever say.
How many of you actually heard
of an economist or the words
that I just uttered?
I don't think you have.
You'll never hear it
in microeconomics,
because microeconomic they
treat all consumers as the same.
Maximize expected utility
subject to a budget constraint.
Or they treat all
producers as the same.
You can maximize profits
subject to a production function
or resource constraint.
What economists
don't recognize is
that there are
different populations
of consumers and producers.
And these populations
arise in different ways.
They're different species.
And different species have
different characteristics.
And so by studying
the different species,
you will come up with
different insights.
But the reason that we don't
have very many insights yet
is because we don't even
speak in these terms.
And therefore, we don't
measure the data in this way.
For example, if I
wanted to today,
the number of retail investors
versus institutional investors
versus broker dealers
versus hedge funds--
if I want to know the biomass
of the different species,
I wouldn't know where to look.
There's no database that has
this information, because we're
not collecting it.
We don't even collect
the information
in the way that would be the
most amenable for analysis
because this is such
a new framework.
So you've got to have the
framework first to figure out
what questions you want to
ask and what data you want
to collect. , And ultimately
after you do that, over time,
you'll be able to see these
kind of patterns emerging.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
contradicts
the view of market
and the [INAUDIBLE]
of market and permits
that say [INAUDIBLE]
market the more [INAUDIBLE]
the more [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Absolutely.
Absolutely, it does
contradict that.
Yeah, this is why I leave this
material to the last lecture,
because, you know, I feel
that it's inappropriate for me
to spend an entire course
in Introductory finance
teaching you what my pet
theories are as opposed
to the mainstream.
You need to know the
basics of what's out there
and how people use the tools.
So that's what we did
for 90% of the course.
But I also would
feel it inappropriate
for me to perpetuate
certain myths
and let you leave this class
without at least understanding
that there's a debate
going on, and that there's
some uncertainty about exactly
what theories apply when.
So you're right.
This does contradict
the conventional wisdom.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right,
[INAUDIBLE] correctly,
the points of [INAUDIBLE]
rational investors.
So right now,
[INAUDIBLE] market.
What's wrong with that?
I mean, after all, we're on a
path to an ineffecient market
again, right?
ANDREW LO: There's nothing
wrong with any of this.
You know, you have to keep
in mind that I'm not making
any value judgments whatsoever.
What I'm trying to explain
to you is a way of thinking,
right?
So I'm trying to give
you a way to reconcile
the various different
kinds of market theories
that have been proposed, the
behavioral versus the rational.
And what I'm arguing is that
neither of these theories
are complete.
They each focus on one
aspect of the market
during one period of time.
And what you need to
do in order to put it
all together is to develop
a super theory that
allows you to understand how
both of these subtheories
are integrated with each other.
And I think this
is what it does.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] had
said that, [INAUDIBLE]
show us pretty much has
a problem, because hedge
funds are pretty much pulling
out as a result [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yeah, but there's
nothing wrong with that.
Hedge funds are pulling out.
And markets will
become less efficient
over the next couple of years.
AUDIENCE: I think it'll be more
efficient, because people that
have [INAUDIBLE] market, right?
So--
ANDREW LO: That
depends on who's left.
That depends on who's
left in the market.
If it's institutional investors
and other sophisticated
investors, you may be right.
But I would argue
that there are going
to be regular investors, like
you and me, that are going
to be left in the marketplace.
And we're going to be
running for the hills
or running for the big returns.
And that's going to be
what drives the market
for the next year or two.
OK?
That's going to be different
than the other periods
where you see
inefficiencies occur,
because the smart
money stayed in,
and the dumb money pulled out.
I shouldn't say "dumb money".
That's kind of value judgment.
The naive money, the
inexperienced money,
the retail investors--
they're the ones that
pulled out, you know, here.
And so here, you had
tremendous amounts
of retail money being applied.
But retail investors,
they ended up
losing a fair bit of
money going forward.
And what was left here
is the hedge fund money.
What I'm arguing is going to
happen over the next year, what
has already happened
over the last year,
is that hedge funds have pulled
out a lot of their money.
So who's left?
Ask yourself, who's left?
When you think about
analyzing a market,
don't just look at it as a
mathematical object and say,
I'm going to write
down the CAPM,
and this is what is
going to tell me.
If you do that, you're
thinking like a physicist,
not like a biologist.
A biologist would say,
what are the species that
are here in this ecology?
And once you tell me
that, I'll tell you
what things are going to happen
over the next year or two.
So let me go to
now how all of this
applies to the current crisis.
I'm not going to talk
about the details of it.
We've already spent
a fair bit of time
this semester talking
about the crisis,
talking about subprime
mortgages, securitization,
the role of all of the
various different folks
that were participating.
But I want to make the following
point based upon the material
that we covered last time.
And that is the fact
that pain protects.
This is a very important,
but rather obvious
point, that I suspect many
of you may have overlooked.
And let me just describe to
you a very simple illustration
of it.
Have any of you
run across people
that have had like
temporary nerve damage?
You know, their arm goes
numb for whatever reason.
Anybody see what
happens to that arm,
you know, over the course
of a couple of weeks
after the nerve damage sets in?
Anybody know?
You have seen situations
where that happens?
Yeah, Mike.
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say, somewhere
there was a little girl who
couldn't feel pain at all.
And she had the-- she
kept clawing her eyes out.
And she was completely
bruised because she just
bumped into everything.
ANDREW LO: That's right.
It's interesting.
When you see these
individuals, they
look like they've been in
a cat fight with a tiger.
You know, they're scratched,
bruised, you know,
they've got these
incredible wounds.
And you ask them, you
know, what happened?
Did you get mugged?
Did you get beaten up?
And they'll say no.
It's just walking around.
It turns out that if you
can't feel in your left arm,
if it's numb, then you
won't know to pull away
when you scrape it on the
edge of a sharp chair,
or you get pricked
by some kind of tool.
You won't know to pull back.
You might just keep
pushing forward.
And you know, there goes
a scratch, and a cut,
and a puncture.
If you can't feel pain,
you can't protect yourself.
Pain protects.
If you think about any kind
of measure you have ever taken
that has protected you,
whether it's pulling money out
of the stock market, whether
it's getting out of a burning
house, whether it's avoiding a
certain situation because you
know that it would likely
turn into a very bad accident,
like driving after you've
had too much to drink--
if you've ever done anything
that involves pulling back
from taking a risk,
it's because you have
felt pain, either current pain.
Or you have felt the
memory of previous pain.
Now let me ask you a question.
Suppose none of you
are feeling any pain.
Will you actually be
able to control yourself
from taking on certain risks?
So this gets back to the
crisis that we're in right now.
If in 2004 or 2005,
you were at one
of these financial
institutions that
invested in these
kinds of securities
or these strategies--
and not everyone did.
So I don't mean to make a
sweeping generalization.
But a number of very
large institutions
seem to have
overextended themselves.
What I want to argue
is that this is not
something that is very easily
preventable unless we impose
certain restrictions in advance,
unless we decide before we ever
enter that situation that we're
not going to do something,
because otherwise it's going to
be impossible for us to avoid
doing it when it feels so
good, when we are in no pain.
I want to be even more specific.
It turns out that financial
gain, monetary reward,
actually stimulates
the same reward
circuitry that cocaine does.
I'm not kidding.
This is not an
analogy or a metaphor.
It's a physiological fact.
Neuroscientists
using fMRI machines
had individuals play games
involving real money--
not a lot of money, but enough
so that it actually registered.
And it turns out that they found
that when people made money
in the MRI machine, that
their brain released dopamine
into a region of the brain
called the nucleus accumbens.
This is exactly
the same thing that
happens when you take cocaine.
Some people have said
that making money
is better than sex.
You know what?
That's actually not
an exaggeration.
It stimulates the same
kind of neural circuitry.
And when you are in this
kind of a mode of reaction,
when your nucleus accumbens
is being hyperstimulated
by dopamine, it will be very
hard, almost impossible for you
to pull back and say, no.
I don't want to.
That's what an
addiction is, frankly.
And for extended
periods of prosperity,
which we have had over
the last 10 years,
it's become
virtually impossible.
I'm not condoning it.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not arguing that these
excesses are just fine
and we excuse them.
I'm actually explaining
a biological fact
about how all of
us are hardwired.
When we're making money, it's
very hard for us to pull back--
so much so, that as a
society, it is possible for us
to overextend ourselves.
And this actually is one role
that regulation can play.
You know, economists have
argued that government
should be involved because
we have public goods.
We have externalities.
We have incomplete markets.
But I think that economists
have missed the most obvious
motivation for regulation,
which is regulation
is a means by which
society prevents itself
from doing the things that it
knows it doesn't want to do
during those periods where it
is incapable of stopping itself
from doing it.
Right?
This is why some people
put their potato chips
on the very top shell
in their kitchen.
They know that they
shouldn't be having too many.
So they make it harder to get
it so that when they get it,
you know, it provides
some kind of distance.
And that doesn't work so well.
I can attest to that.
But I'll give you
another example
I'll give you another
example that's
a little bit more direct.
In every state in
the United States,
we impose fire codes on
builders, fire codes that
require you to have a
minimum number of exits,
to have well-lit exit
signs that you can see,
to have visible fire
alarms, to have sprinkler
systems in the ceiling.
All of this stuff costs money.
It's actually very
expensive to put it.
Do you ever wonder
why we have those?
In other words, why not
let the free market work?
Let people be free to choose.
Those of you that
are nervous Nellies
that are worried
about a fire, you
will simply pay
more for buildings
that have all these goodies.
And then we can
have other buildings
that don't have any
of these protections.
And let people be
free to choose.
Why don't we do that?
That's a perfect equilibrium
from an economist
point of view.
Well, you know why?
It's because in that
free-to-choose world,
none of you will choose the
more expensive building.
And the reason is simple.
It's because when you
assess the probability
of a fire on any given day,
you put a weight of zero
to that event.
I don't any of you came
into this classroom
today thinking hmm,
if there's a fire, who
am I going to have to step
over to get out of that exit?
Maybe you are
thinking about that.
That's why you guys
are sitting here.
But we don't think about
it, because it's not
part of our cognitive
process to focus
on every possible eventuality.
We don't have an infinite
computing machine on our heads.
So we assign certain
events zero probability.
And when you do, you
will pay nothing for it.
So there will be
nobody that will
pay for sprinklers, in which
case, it won't get done.
And as we know, when
it doesn't get done,
eventually, you have a fire.
And during that fire, you really
wish you had those sprinklers.
And it'll be too late to
put them in at that time.
So we regulate.
We regulate because
we know ourselves.
And we know that during
certain situations,
we will not act in a way that
we would like ourselves to act.
So we prevent ourselves
from doing that
by developing these laws that
we just simply have to follow.
Well, that can be done
as well for problems
like leverage credit and so on.
So the point is
that risk management
doesn't work unless we are able
to experience pain and fear.
And profits are a very
potent anesthetic.
They're like a drug.
And the more profit you have,
for a long enough period
of time, you become a lot less
anxious about asking questions,
because you're not
feeling any pain.
You're not feeling pain, so you
won't ask the tough questions.
And you won't scale
back the risks
while everybody else seems
to be doing just fine.
So the point is that
proper balance is the key.
We have to have a proper
balance of fear, greed,
and logical analysis.
And if we know that
there are periods
where that proper balance
will be out of kilter,
that's the role that regulation
can play during those periods.
OK?
So what do we what do we
think about going forward?
Well, clearly the
fear of the unknown
magnifies the
problems that were in.
Flight to liquidity
is likely to persist.
And we really are
going to have to think
more carefully about
developing better analytics.
And ultimately, what
we're going to see over
the next couple of years
is a tremendous period
of innovation--
some of it good, some of it bad.
But we're going to use
the current situation
to really improve and expand
the current infrastructure
for the coming decades.
So as one of the Obama
transition managers mentioned,
a crisis is a terrible
thing to waste.
The next year or two is a
golden opportunity for us
to take advantage of
the crisis by motivating
ourselves to change the
regulatory infrastructure.
Right?
If things are going
well, then there's
no point in trying to
change anything, right?
Don't mess with success.
You've heard that before.
The point is that
right now, we're
in a situation where we can
actually change something.
And so the adaptive
markets would tell us
that this is our way of
creating that infrastructure
to build for the coming growth.
So in conclusion, I would argue
that finance and economics are
a lot more like
evolutionary biology
than they are like physics.
We really have to take a look
at the evolutionary perspective.
And the bottom line
is whether or not
you are going to survive.
That's what we all care about.
That's what we
ultimately strive to do.
And if you understand
this about markets,
you'll have a much better
chance of surviving.
So from the perspective
of 401, the material
we've learned in
this course, we've
gone over the rational
approach to analyzing value
in various kinds of
market interactions.
And just be aware that
for the most part,
that may work reasonably well.
But for extreme circumstances,
periods of extreme wealth,
as well as periods of
extreme market distress,
prices may not be in-line with
what our analytical framework
suggests.
And at that point, you
need to reassess and try
to come up with alternatives.
What those are, we
currently don't know.
We don't have a
good theory for what
happens when the traditional
analytics break down,
because up until
recently, nobody
would be even
willing to consider
that the traditional analytics
would ever break down.
OK?
So this whole area
is relatively new.
And as I mentioned, at the
beginning of this lecture,
if you do a search
for adaptive markets,
you're going to only
find my name attached
to that at this point.
It's not really a theory that's
come into even common parlance,
never mind general acceptance.
It's a conjecture at this point.
It's an alternative to the
current received wisdom.
But the hope is that over time,
as we understand more and more
about these interactions, we'll
be able to develop alternative.
So then, I'm hoping that
a few years from now,
I will be able to
tell all of you,
this is a theory for markets
when they are normal.
And this is a theory for
markets under certain kinds
of distress.
And at that point, we will have
a complete theory of markets
under all circumstances.
But we're still a few
years away from that.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: There are a number
of economists the value
that the financial
sector in the US
was already among the
most regulated sectors.
But partially these regulations
caused [INAUDIBLE] Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac.
And so actually, I would
argue for the opposite.
And do you think
that the regulation
should be fixed because it's
wrong, or you should add more?
ANDREW LO: Well, I don't
think we should add more.
I would argue that we
don't need more regulation.
We need better
regulation, smarter,
more adaptive regulation.
So to your point,
the banking sector,
which is where the majority
of these problems sit today,
the banking sector is
the most regulated sector
of all in all of
the financial world.
And the next most regulated
sector is the insurance sector.
And you have
problems there, too.
So on the one hand, you
could argue that gee,
it's all this regulation
that's created it.
I don't believe that either.
And the reason is that
a lot of these problems
started in 1999 and
after when we actually
dismantled some
of the regulation,
in particular the
Glass-Steagall Act.
We dismantled that in 1999.
And by the way, that wasn't
done by the Republicans.
Bill Clinton signed that.
So there's blame to share
across both political parties.
This is not a political
problem, per say.
So we reduced regulation.
We allowed banks to be
more like hedge funds.
We allowed hedge funds
to be more like banks.
And we got ourselves into the
problem that we face today.
So it's not more regulation.
We have to be smarter about
what we're regulating.
And that's what I'm
hoping that we will
do over the next few years.
OK, well, that's it.
That's it for
Introductory Finance.
What I want to do now in just
the last 15 or 20 minutes,
I'm going to give you a
near-death experience,
because you get to
see the entire course
flash before your very eyes.
I want to go over what
we've done to-date
and try to make sense of it all.
And then I'll tell
you a little bit
about what you might be in store
for with classes in the future.
So let's start at
the very beginning.
I started with this motivation--
mathematics plus money
is equal to finance.
And I hope that I've
delivered on that.
In other words, we've got
very different approaches
to investments.
At the one in the
spectrum, James Simons,
at the other, Warren
Buffett, and, of course,
Jack Welch in-between.
And each of these individuals
brings unique skills
and insights into the
investment process.
And what we wanted
to do in this course,
was to try to distill some
of the basic principles
and the language of finance that
all three of these individuals
would agree are
sort of the building
blocks of understanding
market dynamics.
And as we started
at the beginning
with this flow model
of the economy,
we said that we were going
to study four components--
households, capital markets,
financial intermediaries,
and non-financial corporations.
That's the financial
system as we know it.
And we began with those six
principles of modern finance.
Now I think you have a
deeper appreciation for it.
As I said, we were
only going to be
able to focus on the first few.
And the latter
principles were going
to be underlying
much of the theories
that you would study
beyond this course.
There's no such thing
as a free lunch.
That's a very basic principle
that we used time and again
in coming up with various
different pricing implications.
And P2 is the
behavioral assumption
that I argued we need
for much of the theories
that we developed.
But what I just told
you in the last lecture
is that there are
occasions where
those behavioral
assumptions, ultimately,
are suspended or
replaced with this kind
of overwhelming
emotional component.
We prefer more money
to less, prefer
money now to money later,
and we prefer to avoid risk.
P3-- all agents act to further
their own self-interest.
That's pretty straightforward.
P4-- financial
market prices shift
to equate supply and demand.
And then P5-- financial markets
highly adaptive-competitive,
and that risk-sharing
and frictions
are central to
financial innovation.
I hope that throughout
the entire course
you've got an appreciation for
all six of these principles.
It's remarkable how such
relatively simple ideas
can have such dramatic
implications as we've developed
over the last 13 weeks.
OK so there are four
sections that we focused
on-- the introduction,
evaluation, risk,
and corporate finance.
And then the final lecture of
"Try to put it all together."
For present value,
the focus really
was defining what an asset is--
a package, a sequence of cash
flows, and the time
value of money,
looking at present value
versus future value,
and focusing on exchange
rates between today, tomorrow,
and other dates.
That was sort of
the key insight.
And once you understand how
to visualize the cash flows
and move money through time, you
understand a very significant
portion of financial analysis.
And then we talked
about some special cash
flows-- perpetuities
and annuities,
which we use for virtually
everything in terms
of valuation.
Very important ideas.
And then we talked a bit about
compounding and inflation.
Fixed-income
securities-- Well, we
talked about applying the
very basic mathematics
of present value to these
pure discount bonds and coupon
bonds.
The relationship between coupon
bonds and discount bonds,
of course, is through arbitrage.
And we also found that
current bond prices
contain enormous
amounts of information
about what's going to
happen in the future.
We talked about spot
rates, forward rates,
yield-to-maturity yield
curve, interest rate, risk.
And then we focused
on corporate bonds.
And I spent some time
giving the example
of how repackaging
corporate bonds, and things
like mortgages, auto loans,
and other securities,
could actually lead
to some very, very
attractive securities for a
variety of different clientele.
For equity securities, we
applied exact same framework
to try to come up with a
value of a future stream
of dividends.
And here, while the
mathematics was pretty similar,
the interpretation differed
in an important way,
because dividends are random,
whereas, in the case of bond
prices, the coupons
are known in advance.
So that's the difference between
fixed-income securities, where
the incomes are
fixed in advance,
versus equity securities,
where there's randomness.
What that randomness
does is to make
the volatility of these
pricing models much greater.
In other words, it's
harder to pin down
what the price of
an equity security
is, because in addition
to all of the risks
that a bond will face--
in other words, the risk of
future changes and interest
rates--
you get the risks of changes
in dividends, earnings,
cash flows, and so on.
We also talked about
valuing companies
using various different
formulas, and then the idea
behind PVGO, the present
value of growth opportunities,
and how that can actually lead
to some tremendous valuation
swings in a company that's based
upon intellectual property.
We then talked about a whole
other set of securities
that most of you probably
haven't come into contact
with-- futures versus forwards.
These are weird securities
in the sense that they're
worth nothing on the day
that you agree to enter
into one of these contracts.
But the reason
they're worth nothing
is that these are bilateral
agreements between two
counterparties
And so both of you
are willing to enter into this
in a willing exchange of cash
flow payments sometime
in the future.
The only reason you're
willing to do that
is because the contract
from an objective standpoint
doesn't have any NPV.
And we see that the marking
to market of futures
makes a very big
difference in terms
of the liquidity characteristics
of that contract.
We see that today with what's
going on in financial markets--
and that using these contracts
both for hedging purposes
and for speculation
is a very key aspect
of this whole industry.
Question?
Zeke?
Oh, okay.
Then the last set of
securities that we spent time
on in this course, is options.
Options are different
from anything else
we've looked at up
until now, because first
of all, their payoffs are
asymmetric; they're kinked.
And by putting together
a portfolio of options,
we can get all sorts
of weird payoffs.
In fact in the
various different exam
questions that
you might get, you
will be asked to try to come up
with different kinds of payoff
structures.
So you need to know a
little bit about how
to put these things
together and what
the various different
payoffs imply
under different circumstances.
We also gave you a very simple
example of an option pricing
strategy, a model, namely,
the binomial pricing model.
Very simple, but it's actually
one of the most heavily used
in industry.
And it's an extraordinarily
flexible and powerful method,
again, based on the principle
of arbitrage, or no free lunch.
We then started introducing risk
into the picture explicitly.
We talked about the size effect,
January effect, value line,
momentum, accruals, and pointed
out that all of these effects
can lead to certain
investment strategies.
Whether or not the
strategies are good or bad
really requires a framework.
We didn't have a
framework at the time.
But I wanted to point
out these anomalies
to just mention that
they are the basis
for a number of investment
products and ideas
over the years.
And so we really need to have
a systematic way of thinking
about how to evaluate not
only these strategies,
but the managers that tout them.
Are they adding value?
Or is this something that really
you could do for yourself?
So we developed this notion
of not so much picking
a stock, or a good
two or three stocks,
but putting together a
whole collection of stocks,
a good portfolio.
And we zeroed in on mean and
variance as the key concepts
to evaluate what is good
and what is not good.
And we deduced the main
result of finance theory
under uncertainty, which is
the capital asset pricing
model in two forms--
the capital market line
for efficient portfolios,
and the security market line
for any kind of security
or portfolio, whether
it's efficient or not.
And this allows us to
resolve the open question
that we started with,
which is, how do we
determine what the appropriate
risk-adjusted discount rate is?
I've said at the very beginning,
let the market determine it.
This allows us to
explicate how it
is that the market might
go about doing so, assuming
rationality.
If people aren't rational,
this goes out the window.
But assuming that they are,
this is a complete theory
for how you determine
risk and expected return.
And using risk an
expected return,
we now have a complete
theory for capital budgeting,
for how to evaluate whether or
not you ought to take a project
or not take a project, OK?
And last and
certainly not least,
we talked about the idea behind
market efficiency, the idea
that you can actually trust
market prices, market rates
of return, market betas, all
of the information that you
glean from market data and
apply them to your decisions.
Can you trust them?
And the answer is sometimes.
When markets are efficient,
when prices fully
reflect all available
information,
the power and the
wisdom of crowds
is very, very compelling.
But there are periods
where the crowd is not
a wise crowd, but an
angry mob, like right now.
So you want to be careful
and not talk to the market
about evaluating your
project when they're
trying to lynch somebody or some
financial institution that's
out there, OK?
And in order to reconcile
efficient markets
with these periods
of insanity, I
proposed this notion
of adaptive markets.
And at least it provides
a consistent framework
for thinking about these
periods of craziness,
as well as periods
of market calm.
So that's it.
That's it for 15.401.
Where you go from
here depends upon what
your career objectives are.
If you're interested in
pursuing investments,
if you want to be a trader,
a portfolio manager,
or get involved in pension asset
management, what you want to do
is to focus on the
investments direction, things
like 15.433 Investments, or
15.437 Options and Futures.
And we have a number of
practical pro seminars
that are taught
by practitioners,
like Seth Alexander, the
current Chief Investment
officer of the MIT Endowment,
or Phil Cooper, former partner
of Goldman Sachs who has his
own private equity company.
There are a number of
these practitioner courses,
as well as the
theoretical courses
that we offer that I would
encourage you to take.
If, on the other
hand, you're looking
for something on the
corporate financial side--
project finance, corporate
financial management,
that kind of approach
requires that you learn more
about capital budgeting,
mergers and acquisitions,
corporate finance, so
15.434 is a good course,
and certain accounting courses.
You might want to take
financial accounting.
Those are the
directions that you
may want to take if you're
interested in pursuing
that career path,
So both of them I think are
extraordinarily exciting.
They all rely on the
material that we've
covered in this course.
And so, you know, you
now have the background
to be able to handle any
and all of that material.